This photograph exemplifies
the harsh reality of war.
A US Marine experiences
an extremely close call
from a Taliban attack.
The dirt wall protecting him
exploding from an enemy bullet.
We can see that the
soldier is in danger,
but what about the person
who took the photo?
The person standing feet
away from this nearly fatal
firefight.
It makes you wonder, is it
worth it to risk your life just
to get the perfect photo?
Photography has been around
since the early 1800s.
And wars, of course,
much longer than that.
Before photography, wars were
reimagined on the canvas.
Heroic paintings created by
artists who weren't there.
Many times, completed long
after the battles were over.
But when people started
to photograph war,
these images helped bring the
realism and the horror of it
to the world, to people living
far away from the conflict.
These images had an immediate
impact on how people saw war.
One of the first major wars
that was covered extensively
by photography was the
American Civil War.
There were other war
photographs before,
but nothing like the coverage
that the Civil War received.
These pictures documented the
soldiers, both living and dead,
in one of the bloodiest
conflicts in history.
The camera technology at the
time couldn't capture action.
No bullets flying,
no soldiers running.
But it could show the impact
and the consequences of war.
One person at the time
even compared the work
of famous Civil War
photographer Matthew Brady
to having the actual
bodies of deceased soldiers
laid at the front
doors of the public.
With the growth
of war photography
and the knowledge that it
can influence the public,
it soon got the attention
of the American government.
During World War I, many
photographs were censored.
Some because the
government didn't
want to give away
troop movement,
but many because
they didn't want
the photographs to negatively
impact morale back home.
World War II saw both the
allied and axis countries
using photography as
a propaganda tool.
America wanted to show the
heroic American soldier,
doing good across the world.
Germany wanted to show
the world something, too.
How well they were
treating prisoners,
and how life wasn't changing
negatively in the countries
they occupied.
Both countries continued
to censor images that
could possibly lower morale.
It might not have been
until the Vietnam War
that Americans once again
saw the horror of conflict.
The images that were sent back
were not censored or screened.
The world was once again
exposed to the reality of war,
and told the truth about what
was happening in Vietnam.
Pictures appeared on the cover
of Time and Life magazines,
and on television
screens around the world.
So it's not a surprise that
back home, the war was not
thought upon as popular.
Today, war journalists
and photographers
are as important as ever.
In an internet era, a world
with instant communication,
they can show what's
happening in almost real time.
We can see the tragedy
that happened yesterday,
or the heroism from
the night before.
Photographers today
are putting themselves
on the front lines of violence
around the world in a fight
to bring you the truth.
What you do with that truth,
well, that's up to you.
To see more photography
that's influenced the world,
check out this episode on
the power of candid photos.
Or watch this one on why
America used these images
as propaganda.
And as always, don't
forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.